warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is advised some of our
viewers may have heard of the extreme
Jesuit oath I mean it the one line
really kind of you know stands out there
in the middle it's like do further more
promise and declare that I will when
opportunity presents make and wage
Relentless War secretly or openly
against all Heretics Protestants and
liberals as I am directed to and it it
was very scandalous in that it it showed
a lot of duplicitous means that they
would use to advance their cause and
obtain means for the order and so it was
it was very much a scandal for the order
and as well as this Extreme Oath but it
was very violent in talking about you
know attacking and killing people and
it's pretty gory yeah it might be too
hot for you to
yeah what's up everyone welcome back to
LED live today we have James Bowen with
us I would say he's quite the walking
encyclopedia when it comes to Biblical
history he also runs the YouTube channel
biblical hope and today he is here to
talk about the Jesuits which is
basically the special forces of the
Roman Catholic church and the Vatican if
you're into New World Order and these
groups the elites that run the world
stick around and you think we're crazy
should stick around too because I
believe by the end of this episode
you'll be convinced there's something
more happening behind the scenes James
take it away thank you thank you for
having me today so you know in case
there's any doubt in your mind as to
whether or not the Jesuits actually are
in power today or how popular they are
let's take a look simply put this
country and this world benefit from your
commitment to Jesuit principles to being
men as a graduate of another great
Jesuit Institution xaver University I
have great affection for the value and
purpose of a Jesuit education wow yeah
there's no questions that's uh for those
of you who don't know that's how Speaker
John Boehner back in the day and uh
obviously a very much a fan of the
Jesuits but um before deep fakes right
right yeah and you know in 2016 there
was a movie released called silence you
guys might have heard about it I think
they had Andrew Garfield in it the same
fellow who played in um he did that
after he did the whole film yeah exactly
and you know it popularized a couple of
Jesuits and there was one scene in
particular that caught my mind and it
reminds me of the crucifixion in some
ways they were given
sake as the Roman soldier offered
vinegar to the dying
Christ I prayed they remembered our
Lord's suffering and took courage and
comfort from it
so they were definitely portraying their
uh members as Martyrs for the cause so
these were this is a movie about Jesuits
yeah so this particular movie um you
know silence they were portraying a
couple of Jesuits over in Japan and uh
we're going to take a look at some of
the history of that here in just a
moment but some of our viewers may have
heard of the extreme Jesuit oath it was
part of the Library of Congress due to
some uh political struggles that took
place back in 1912 between Eugene
bonniwell and Thomas Butler and this
oath was brought to to light there have
been many people that have claimed that
it was a forgery based off of some
forgeries from fellow by the name of
Robert wear and it was classed with
another document called the secreta
Monita that uh was the secret
instructions of the Jesuits this second
document right here was originally
discovered in the Jesuits College of
pbor West philia in a cupboard in the
rector's room and a second copy in the
city of Prague in 1611 now gretzer one
of the Jesuits affirmed that the Monita
was a forgery and the problem was is
later on there was a work found in the
British museum tucked away from 15 96 20
years before the alleged forgery in
which the secreta Monita is copied and
it was very scandalous in that it it
showed a lot of duplicitous means that
they would use to advance their cause
and obtain means for the order and so it
was it was very much a scandal for the
order and as well as this Extreme Oath
and I'm not going to read all of this
here because I I'm just going to
challenge the viewer to maybe take a
look and see what kind of uh what what
kind of means they would promote but it
was very violent in talking about you
know attacking and killing people and
it's pretty gory yeah it might be too
hot for YouTube yeah I mean it the one
line really kind of you know stands out
there in the middle it's like do further
more promise and declare that I will
when opportunity presents make and wage
Relentless War secretly or openly
against all Heretics Protestants and
liberals as I am directed to you know
the first time I ever heard of the
was actually when I read the book The
cre controversy which is really just a
historical piece like this author Ellen
White she quotes historians this is not
our own agenda or ideas or anything and
um many people have been blessed by it
including me and that's where these
historians describe as the Jesuits were
put into place to counter the
Reformation that was happening right the
Martin Luthers the zwingle the um John
Wesley all those people who stepped up
and shareed the truth of whatever the
Roman Catholic Church is teaching is not
biblical and the Jesuits came in and
secretly mingled with the Protestants
joined their churches to then counter it
yeah I I got into an argument recently
with a Catholic over the matter because
he was trying to show from chat GPT that
you know he was asking chat GPT is the
Jesuit o real and of course chat GPT was
trying to say well it's inconsistent
with Jesuit teachings and not
representative of what Rome taught but
to that end let's take a look at some of
those documents this is the pontifical
romanum and it would it contained in it
the Abbott's oath you can see the
connection here to Clement VII and urban
VII as well and one of the one of the
parts of the Abbott's oath was I swear
that Heretics and schismatics and Rebels
to our Lord the Lord Pope or his
successors I will to the extent of my
power persecute and beat down propos
pers
andabo okay so the Lord is the Pope
well that was part of uh canon law and
distinc 96 of decrums uh graani uh the
decal of of gracian but um you know you
got to remember the context back in the
day when the Jesuit oath was released
there were a lot of people that were
legitimately concerned about what
Catholics were wanting for America for
example in the Catholic register we read
there is no crime that the doting
Warrior charges against us to which we
must not plead guilty he says that we
are trying to make the United States a
Catholic country we are most certainly
are doing all in our power to accomplish
it wow and and look at who is uh running
the judicial system now right MH all of
the the what do you call them the the
Supreme Court the Supreme Court the
judges are Catholic in a nation that was
founded as a Protestant Nation why
because they were fleeing the
persecution that was happening in Europe
where millions of Christians died
because they would not recant their
Protestant beliefs and the Catholic
church was forcing them to well you
either got to believe our beliefs which
were based in paganism I'm I'm sorry to
say but that's the reality of it it was
paganism that was got mixed with
Christianity and the Christians said
we're going to the United States and
look at the United States right now it's
turning Catholic yeah in the western
Watchmen they said that the church has
persecuted only a Tyro in church history
will deny that and they went on further
and stated that you know she gives no
bonds that such things will not occur
again so they they were very bold in the
uh their idea that you know the church
has persecuted we may do it again if we
feel
threatened and there were encouragements
entered into the Congressional Record
from like the Detroit Journal where when
the church needed armed men to enlist as
Crusaders the young men of the church
shouldered the muskets and saber and
obeyed the orders of the church when the
church wanted to get rid of the SARS
since the faithful arose in mass and
extinguished them the church may have to
call on you to defend her her rights in
this country and I know that the young
men will obey the church and take up
arms to exterminate the enemies of the
Roman Catholic Church you know what a
lot of people don't know is that the
Roman Catholic Church in the Vatican was
a political system MH yeah they were
ruling over Kings Kings bowed down to
the pope it was due to the French
Revolution um that the pope was removed
in
1798 mm and uh that's when a pope was
removed and it became just a Rel
religious institution but you know how
many Christians are out there saying
like no we want to have a church and
state
combined like system again that's
dangerous and we see why and I'll just
add that we see that we see actually
heads of each country going before the
pope and kneeling and kissing his ring
so he's still in control of all of it
and why are they not doing that to any
other Protestant Pastor nobody the
Protestant pastors are going to the pope
as well yeah yeah there there were calls
to organize into secret societies and
give them military training and and
whatnot this was this was Pope Leo the
13th quoted in the Christian July
1914 but really you know this kind of
organization and military force and
coercion it it was really something that
began a long time ago and you know one
of the things that I read from this book
The Great controversy is that in the
13th century was established the most
terrible engine of the papacy the
Inquisition and you know there were many
things about the Inquisition I think
that are being downplayed today but if
you go back to like the inquisitor's
manual itself from Nicholas Amor this
was one of the propositions on page 199
that the whole city must be burnt on
account of the Heretics who live in it
whoever SE pleases May seize and kill
any Heretics how do you guys think that
compares to what Christ did in Luke 9 do
you guys remember the disciples came
there was a city that rejected
him and they were like hey you know can
we call down fire and burn the city and
and what Christ do he turned and rebuked
them and said you know not what manner
of spirit you are of is is Nicholas am
is the Catholic Church's Inquisition
manual is it is it matching The Same
Spirit of Christ in Luke 9 I think the
dangerous thing is when somebody has so
much power that they're able to
Define and more make all the definitions
you know we say who the Heretics are and
you look at the Jesso oath you know it
was in there we you know we're going to
persecute all Heretics
Protestants you've just said all of them
are are
Heretics
so that that's setting a very dangerous
precedent because then they're the ones
that make all the decisions about you
know who lives and who dies and you look
at church history ancient church history
that's that's a
very
um how do I want to say it it's a very
um it's not a very comforting place to
be for everybody else you know the ones
who aren't in power so to speak mhm and
who aren't abiding by their beliefs yeah
yeah there's no freedom of thought yeah
you know at this time um around the time
of the Reformation the order of the
Jesuits was created the most cruel
unscrupulous and Powerful of all the
champions of popery cut off uh from
every Earthly tie and human interest
dead to the claims of natural affection
reason and conscience holy silence they
knew no rule no tie but that of their
order
and we're going to take a look here you
know ultt theocracy by Lady Queensboro
indicates that the Jesuits were
ultimately involved in the Inquisition
because it was Ignatius lyola himself
who procured its erection in Portugal in
1545 to 46 so they were very much
involved in fact if you go to the chz
jzu in Rome today there's an allegorical
statue of Mary casting out hus and
Luther and so they they were very much
involved in countering the reformation
and trying to put a halt on on that
their story though began back uh much
earlier uh to Ignatius lyola himself he
was born Inigo Lopez in lyola In the
Castle of lyola he was a colorful
character Brash ruy and unruly and
easily offended he was born to a wealthy
family the police records of the day
said that he was kind of a violent and
vindictive fellow it's kind of
interesting to see though how he's
portrayed today very different from what
the the historical record indicates he's
very much popularized you can take a
look at that right herea is lost I say
we
[Music]
fight he wants to become a pilgrim he
wants to go to Jerusalem and beg his way
there like the holy pilgrims of old but
he Yola what will people
say if you could hear the voice of God
would you want to keep it
secret you know what this council is
capable of do you really want to die so
that Council right there was actually
the Inquisition he himself was brought
up on trial for being part of the
alumbrados which was the Illuminati at
that time but what happened is early on
in that Siege of Pamplona his leg was
Shattered by a cannonball and ultimately
his dreams of a warrior kind of ceased
and so he found himself going to the
mountains of monserat to visit an image
and this is the monastery that's now
there in monserat it's it's very you
know uh well gilded I guess would be the
term to describe it but he spent three
days in confession an entire night
before this black Madonna statue and
committed himself to Mary he went off to
Jerusalem to to conquer for Christ what
the Crusades failed to do he thought he
was going to do himself so it kind of uh
shows uh his self-esteem if you will um
yeah what he just became a different
kind of warrior yeah exactly and he
couldn't go ultimately so he ended up
staying at monesa and in Mona he spent
10 months in a cave and in exhaustion
had dreams and visions and he had many
fanciful dreams he saw lights flashing
he believed he chased Satan like a dog
with a whip and uh but later on in in
1534 him and six others mostly of
castian origin all students of the
University of Paris met in monar 3
outside of Paris and pronounced Promises
of poverty Chastity and obedience now
there are some things that took place in
his history very much ult uh in in
practice he was said to have some occult
Powers such as levitation and you know
other stuff that was Supernatural but um
you know guys is is Supernatural
levitation is that evidence of Truth No
No by uh solar scriptura is one of the
statements that came out of the
Reformation which means by the
scriptures and the scriptures alone and
the scriptures do not approve of any of
that or prove that any of this is
biblical you know you know one of the
interesting stories if you go back in in
history is it's an apocryphal uh Act of
Peter um that Simon maggus himself was
said to have levitated by the assistance
of demons and Peter kneeled down and
prayed and then Simon Magus fell down
and died it was it was supposedly a
legend or story that took place but you
know that act of levitation alone uh the
early church allegedly faced problems
like that as well that were not in
origin from from the the true gospel but
you know the Satan trying to to manifest
himself and I say I say uh allegedly cuz
you know the apoc of Peters it's there's
some discussion over what's truth and
what's error there but in time he was
accepted by the pope and confirmed
through the bull regini Militan eesi and
you've got a copy of it right there he
was sworn to uh sworn to the pope and
given all sorts of powers to
excommunication to Aid the society to
confirm exercise and dispense plener
indulgences all sorts of power and
initially early on they first proved
themselves in the hospitals very kind of
humble likee which you know gave the
presumption or or the um the look of
piety if you will
mhm it reminds me of another fellow so
the perspective that I came to from
medicine was always very much involved
with the person as opposed to the
disease that happens to be in a person
it really goes way back in my training
of service for others but with a very
strong theme of intellectual rigor and
integrity and honesty which again it it
something that I didn't deliberately
choose it it was there from the almost
the minute I was born with my parents
and then the idea of going into a long
period of Education under the Jesuits
was just very natural to get me to where
I am today h do you guys know about that
with foui I did not know that about him
but I know that in The Lodges of
Freemasons as well as the Jesuits that's
their first move is to go into the
community and do community work to get a
reputation of kindness and goodness not
only so that they can have that kind of
Disguise under you know under everything
they're doing but
also to um kind of get
their I don't know get information
usually I find it really interesting cuz
I I'm sure some people will bring up oh
look at look at the pope he is a Jesuit
Pope and look how much good he does but
that is literally how the Jesuits were
established like you were saying they
were infiltrating the education system
they were infiltrating churches they
were supposed to look like Pious on the
outside so that you will be deceived
right and uh doesn't the Bible say be
aware of lions and sheep skin right and
that's the exact thing and the same
thing with Jonathan roomy who placs
Jesus in The Chosen who is a Jesuit and
if you look at our documentary that we
have on our YouTube channel for free
about chosen you'll see that he admits
to also be a knight's Templar which is
on par with a 33rd degree Freemason so
look it up yeah these these guys were
known also though for some fanaticism so
Xavier one of the early Jesuits uh was
requested by one of the patients to
scrape out an absis and he felt rather
squeamish about it so he put his hand
which was covered in the pent matter to
his mouth in order to put his
self-control to the extreme test so it
was this idea of just like crafting the
will into total submission and there
were other stories of them you know
laying down in the bed of of a man who
Who had pediculosis who um you know had
was covered with vermin all sorts of of
extreme things that were taking place
you know I don't ever hear um I've never
read a story about any of the the
gospels or early
church or U or Christ doing such extreme
things you know like that wasn't the
kind of Faith practices they had or
healing
practices um they established schools so
there were schools that uh that they
used to educate the masses uh in scores
of languages in India and Japan at first
only 60 of them were allowed but later
on uh with the bull exposit debitum of
Julius thei in 1550 they ended up having
more of them come in they became the
teachers of the people Mato rii is is a
prime example of of how they infiltrated
the court system and you know ultimately
there was a lot of impact that they had
with the Counter Reformation and these
were three Jesuits that were heavily
involved you've got
uh alkazar Francisco robera and Manuel
Luna alkazar being the one to really
bring in preterism and Luna and robera
are definitely futurism and one of the
things that I find interesting is Theo
de de Messias in Gloria majestad was
actually written under a pen name of a
Jew Juan josephat benra as a means of uh
of of getting it sold better and
ultimately down stream this kind of
theology about the es eschatological
idea of
futurism was brought through Darby and
some of the other Protestants to America
and it's now taught at the Dallas
Theological Seminary today so could you
explain for those who don't know what is
prism what is futurism right so
preterism is the idea that all of the
events of Revelation have already
happened way in the ancient past that
you know the Antichrist that was all
Nero and that was it all happened 2,000
years ago and futur ism is this idea
that all of that about Antichrist and
everything is yet in the future and it's
all set in the future you know long time
down the road and really both views were
proposed because both of them took equal
uh distraction or or equal heat off of
Rome from Protestants idea of
historicism which identified the
Catholicism and and the the pope uh as
Antichrist and so it was very effective
for them to get Protestants distracted
and off of what they were originally
believed so I find it really interesting
that we can see the ideologies and the
beliefs of the Vatican having seeped
into today's protestantism because how
many people do you hear today who say
well that are you know in certain
denominations or most denominations that
say oh the Antichrist the Vatican but
think about it if you are part of the
Methodist Church or part of uh the
Lutheran Church Martin Luther was saying
this right and and John Wesley was
saying this all of these individuals out
of which these church denominations came
said this is the uh Antichrist but you
don't hear it today anymore MH right but
but why because the Jesuits came in and
said let's distract them let's say let's
come up with other theological ideas so
they think it's in the past or in the
future and it's not us mhm yeah you know
Revelation warns about this system that
would deal in The Souls of men and you
know one of the things that I I found
sad was in Paraguay the establishment of
the reductions there the Jesuit plan of
training and evangelization that took
place whether they intentionally desired
it or not um involved keeping the
Indians in as much ignorance as possible
but slavery was never inconsistent with
uh Catholic principles in
1866 Pope pas the 9th himself declared
that slavery considered as such in its
essential nature is not at all contrary
to the Natural and Divine Law and there
can be several just titles of slavery
and these are referred to by approved
theologians and commentators of the
Sacred cannons so is very sad that the
the the sort of bondage that took place
when you talk about the sacred cannons
this is the tradition in the forefathers
of the Catholic church that you can't
actually refute when they say tradition
they're like it must be tradition and
the Bible or whatever but they never go
directly off of the Bible or anything
else and in practice they put tradition
over the Bible yes of course yeah you
know part of their the secret to their
power was how they got involved with the
Kings and rulers of the world Louis the
15th was a homosexual his Confessor was
a Jesuit and it was through the means of
the confessional that they became able
to know the secrets of state but also be
able to wield those with power uh to
hold it as a sort of Leverage and
manipulate the rulers of the world so
they had so like manipulate him because
he was gay and they didn't want he
didn't want people to know well it you
know I'm not going to make uh something
there that I can't explicitly that I
can't support from the uh from the
writings but you know think about the
kind of power if you're if you're having
um whatever secret sin in your life uh
that you're confessing to someone else
and they have you know then they have
means to leverage it and you know do
whatever they want with it um it creates
a a really powerful uh you know system
there that's very dangerous yeah they
were founded though upon uh this sort of
structure where you had Jesuit
individuals who would answer to a
provincial and then superiors who would
answer to the General in this uh order
right here and part of this was
predicated upon the idea of having all
of one's failures or
imperfections uh being reported and
denounced to the superiors so you could
never trust anybody it was this uh way
of reporting on your fellow uh Jesuit
and it created a structure where the top
General kind of knew about everything
that was going on and you know to me it
kind of reminds me of the devil his role
to be an accuser of the Brethren you
know that's what he would want as part
of his structure and that's what I find
in in what they teach works very well if
you're at the top and you know a lot of
people see a lot of the Jesuits out
there as you know good kind men that uh
what's what could be wrong with this
Society but you got to understand that
there's a lot of different levels you
have novices Scholastics temporals
coadjutors professor of three vows four
vows and then the Masters and it takes a
lifetime to get to the Master Level and
it's set up in such a way so that they
can hold a front to the world and not be
known for what really goes on behind the
scenes uh in G's doctrine of the Jesuits
the general himself usually stood
towards the pope much as a powerful
Grand feudatory of the Middle Ages did
towards a weak titler Lord Paramount so
the Jesuit General himself is very very
powerful in the 17th century uh baronia
said that our father General as all know
governs Rome itself and the popedom we
make war at our pleasure bet one Prince
and another between a prince and his
subjects usurp dominion over cities and
countries fearing no discovery of our
action since our Commerce is chiefly
with great men we know every public
secret and Canon singular way dispatch
Heretics and enemies of the Roman Court
O this is how campaigns political
campaigns are run this is completely the
um healan dialectic right there what is
that oh my goodness it's basically using
both parties that are running and all
the people who are for against their
motives and mixing it like he's saying
making war with each other so that
there's anger and there's heated um
feelings on both sides so you get
everyone pushing everybody to a
direction that you want to push them
which is towards the middle yeah and
then you have the solution yeah and the
solution is not really what everybody
else wants it's what the person who's
crafted the um the whole War you know
it's it's their solution so that they
wind up in control through Strife though
you have to create it through Strife
yeah this is the general today uh this
man holds a lot of power his name's
Arturo Sosa now this is the black pope
correct yes yes this is this is the
Jesuit General today what does it mean
the black pope you have the white one
which is set out to be the kind again
loving man who's in the Vatican Francis
yeah yeah and you have this guy who's
actually pulling all the puppet strings
of the white Pope and the Vatican and
everybody else in the world and the
propaganda that's being
yeah I guess brought up it's interesting
nobody's really hears about this guy you
know of course not yeah so the other one
is the face and this guy is actually the
the commander oh interesting if you're
in a secret society you don't talk about
it yeah you're not supposed to know it's
like Fight Club you know the first rule
of Fight Club is we don't talk about
Fight Club right it's the same thing
with skull and bones and all those guys
it's like if you're part of it you don't
talk about it right yeah you know one of
the things that uh happened is it
arrived at such a height that the
Italian aqua Viva became father General
he gave his hand to be kissed as the
pope his toe so you had to show
deference to the general and father Dosa
um blasphemously preached that in the
last days God has spoken to us by his
son Ignatius by whom he hath appointed
heir of All Things by whom also he made
the world wow making ignacius Lola Jesus
is what they're saying that's blasphemy
like you said they became such a
political problem all over Europe there
were pictures like this of the Pope you
know Fanning the Flames that burned down
London and starting fires in every
country being involved in things you
know the rulers of Europe got so sick of
it that they eventually kicked them out
of Paris Portugal and Spain and I think
they were also kicked out of Japan now
don't quote me on this but I'm pretty
sure that they were they tried to kick
out all of the foreigners and there was
pressure being put your your dad told me
about this there was pressure being put
on them to let them back in because the
Jesuits wanted to come back in mhm yeah
and you know in in
1762 we can see right here that there
was a um a denouncement in the Hostile
press and in
1767 uh there were secret orders to be
open at Sunrise where all the members of
the Society of Jesus from Charles
Spanish domains and confiscating all
their goods they wanted all of them
removed and the closing sentence read if
a single Jesuit even though sick or
dying is still be found in the area
under your command after the embarking
prepare yourself to face summary
execution so Europe was like so tired of
all the Intrigue they were done that's
why they didn't want him in America too
yeah yeah and ultimately they were they
were suppressed under uh Pope Clement
the 14th who issued a suppression in his
Dominus acor noer right here and you
know it wasn't long though before they
were revived and Pope Pas II put the
Jesuits back into Power he was the same
Pope in the smallpox crisis so they
almost had like a like a an massive
pandemic in their day and um that was
one of the things that happened at that
time as well is the Jesuits came back
into Power I just found that kind of
coincidental and interesting but uh you
know there were people in the United
States who knew about the dangers of
this order and John Adams was not happy
about the rebirth he was really
concerned that it would be a threat to
religious liberty but nevertheless
recognized that we offered principles of
religious liberty here in the United
States and so there wasn't anything that
uh that was going to be done about it
but you know one of the things that
really concerns me is what these folks
actually believed for example this Creed
right here I believe in two Gods one is
son father and mother
metaphorically and he goes on mother
father may be equally attributed to God
and the Blessed Virgin as if they were
both Hodes o so it it doesn't look uh
particularly well and this was a copy of
that Creed um from uh Alonso Vargas
tolani right here and you can read it in
the Original Latin
there they were known to be involved in
idolatry which craft and carrying images
in in ways that were not uh
acceptable and one of the things that I
want to point out here in Ignatius of
Loyola spiritual exercises as well is
this principle that is a Jesuit axom
right
here and you know what what I see as
white I will believe as black if the
hierarchy of the church so declares it
to be right so you had to turn over
everything in your mind you could not
offer any kind of reason no reasoning
Powers uh that you could retain you
Hades exactly they that the sky is red
you must say the sky is red yeah the the
Jesuit aim was parende aav it was the
idea of being a corpse yeah so you know
in the spiritual exercises um one of the
things that I find is a certain element
of coldness for example separating
himself from all friends and
acquaintances when this was going on
there were stories told about Xavier and
some of the early Jesuits how sometimes
they would pass you know in their
lifetime like a few miles away from
loved ones on their journey to another
country but they would not even stop and
go and visit their loved ones because
they were on a mission and they wouldn't
even take the time it was just basically
you're supposed to get cold from any
sort of Love or or rational emotion if
you're dead exactly it makes you wonder
if there's a
certain personality type that's drawn to
that like a narcissistic yeah that you
know they person that desires power a
person that that can easily cut off
other people has no love for them no no
earthly ties none of that I mean that
just not I mean humanity is broken but
even in our Brokenness it doesn't seem
normal we would call that unhealthy yeah
you know one of the things that they had
was these breath prayers where you would
focus on a particular word and repeat it
over and over and breathe while yeah
exactly you know kind of shutting down
your frontal lobe your ability to think
and process and just like self hypnos
yourself and so that's meditation in
eastern um what do they call it Eastern
mysticism that's
right yeah and you know they were very
much pantheistic as well uh thinking
about God in the plants and
vegetation um likewise making a temple
of me being created in the likeness and
image of his divine majesty and
believing that Christ or or God was in
all things so it it very similar to
Eastern religions exactly and you can
find some similarities there in in some
of the concepts here for example um
astrological healing certain things
there that you might find in the East
but uh they have definitely a connection
to Hollywood in some ways as well aanus
cure and the magic lantern you can find
evidence of his testing and working on
the principles of that as well as things
like surround sound so if you think
about how you know theater is today it
its Origins are rooted in the Jesuits in
what they
studied now are you guys ready to get
into some uh some documents some pretty
scary documents let's do it yeah so um
this is the Cardinal uh Jesuit Sir
Robert bellerine very famous in
Catholicism respected Cardinal and one
of the things that I found interesting
was in speaking about Luther Lu Luther
said you know the church never burned
anybody and his response was that that
proves Luther's either ignorance or
impudence because the church put an
infinite number uh you know to death
were and they were burned to death and
either Luther didn't know about it or he
was ignorant and he goes further and he
says that you know some people say like
experience shows that terror is not
useful he says I I I reply experience
proves the contrary for the donatus
manquin and alenes were routed and
annihilated by arms so I got a question
is Terrorism how we advance the gospel
yeah really not under Jesus Christ's
gospel no I really wonder at what point
Luther said that because you know in his
he had become a monk and at some point
he made a journey to Rome thinking that
this was going to be a highlight of his
ministry experience he got there and
after he saw what he
saw he
left and he said if there's a hell Rome
is surely built on it yeah you know so
it makes me wonder was this before that
experience where he was like H you know
the church hasn't done anything you know
that versus like later it seems like he
would be more inclined to believe
that yeah there was corruption right
yeah this you know this one this Jesuit
Alonso totani said that the pope can
kill by a single word for having
received the pasture for the Sheep has
he not received the right of cutting the
throats of wolves that's great see this
Jesuit Antonio Escobar said that
children are obliged to denounce their
parents or relations who are guilty of
heresy although they know that they will
be burnt they may refuse them all
nourishment and permit them to die with
Hunger or they may kill them as enemies
who violate the rights of humanity you
know the sad thing is that kind of stuff
happened if you think about St
Bartholomew's Massacre one of the one of
the Jesuits that was involved right
there um had been uh Edmund AER had gave
a sermon in Bordeaux descri describing
the St Bartholomew's Day Massacre in
parents in oron as an Angelic execution
of divine judgment mhm he claimed that
the Judgment would continue in Bordeaux
a prediction borne out by the massacre
there several days later sounds like a
very Angelic execution when you kill
innocent children so Twisted wow you
know I I think of some circumstantial
evidence for that extreme Jesuit oath
uel saw said that to the Tyrant who
governs I can resort to Justice if from
another source someone tyrannically
governing a justly acquired domain
cannot be deprived of it without a
public trial one sentence has been
passed however anyone can execute he can
also be deposed by the people even those
who have sworn obedience to him if he
does not want to be corrected by warning
but he who sees his tyrannical power any
one of the people may kill him for he is
a Public Enemy of the people so the
question you got to ask here is who
determines whether or not someone is a
just
ruler it's not it's not anything
biblical yeah it's all based at
whoever's on the top Yeah there the ones
who say now it looks like you have a
character from Assassin's Creed down
there in the corner yeah it um it
definitely I had to include that because
you know you think about Assassin's
Creed who did those who does that best
represent and when you look back in
history uh these guys kind of fit the
bill I feel like very simar yeah so and
there's there's a lot of uh you know
stuff Illusions to that uh um some of
those some of the societ ities and what
not in that game now regarding
homosexuality Jesuit Antonio Escobar
said also said that clerics who commit
the crime of sodomy do not incur the
penalty of the bull if it is not
exercised more than two or three times
so um he also Manuel saw went on to
state that to copulate before the
marriage blessing is either no sin or is
a slight sin but it is also expedient if
marriages delayed a great
deal definitely teaching stuff that that
uh is is just making it up as they go
yeah
exactly all the names which the
scriptures are given to Christ once it
appears that he is above the church all
these same names are given to the pope
now you know claiming the names of
Christ if the Pope's doing that is that
a fulfillment of second Thessalonians 2
yeah yeah I mean you know claiming to be
above
God uh he went on to state that the
Catholic church this is actually
Cardinal bellerine teaches that every
virtue is good and that every VI evil
but if the pope should he in commanding
vices or forbidding virtues the church
would be bound to believe that vices are
good and virtues evil unless he wished
to sin against
conscience very interesting statement it
reminds me of uh the decum graani distin
40 that Martin Luther was had a problem
with where basically it said that that
the pope could lead the entire world to
hell and no man May judge him wow so he
is above God above judgment yeah and and
they have a philosophy you know that end
justifies the means just like doesn't
there's there's no morality in that and
I think it's a very frustrating um
philosophy that that people propagate
but it makes sense if you look at their
oath you know it's just like we're going
to do whatever it takes to accomplish
whatever our goal is and we are
justified in doing it yeah this this
Jesuit here said that it is a new
privilege that Christ added through the
sacrament one may be justified without
love I mean that lies in the face of the
chap just don't question any of it just
do it yeah they went on to to say things
like this it is lawful to use knowledge
acquired with the help of a demon oo I
mean that's Escobar right there and
there there was a question that was
asked Antonio Escobar that you know
servants May secretly steal from their
masters as much as they judge the labors
to be worth and he said if for some
reason they cannot obtain equality and
Court independently they could
compensate themselves extrajudicially in
secret it's just lawlessness that's all
it is it's lawlessness it's just saying
do whatever you have to do in any
situation and it's fine yeah and then
also that they want to even use demons
to do that so that this really shows the
lawlessness not Christianity yeah the
demonic stuff who who are they serving
MH well the Witchcraft and everything
that you were mentioning before it's
right there yeah and it gets even worse
you know uh Isaiah 8:20 we read to the
law and to the testimony if they speak
not according to this word it is because
there is no light in them but this
particular one Petra alagona said that
if God says to murder Rob and fornicate
it is our duty whoa that this is what I
mean we were talking about earlier that
they put tradition over the Bible right
right and and this is why it was called
the Dark Ages because they withheld all
of the scriptures from the common people
and said well only the clergy of the
church can interpret the Bible which was
in Latin which was not the language of
the people which means I can the clergy
can tell you what it means based on what
they want it to mean they can take it
out of context yes yeah yeah this um
this one right here Richard aren
suggested that if anyone consults the
Stars the Divination may be devoid of
all
sin and you know to that end we can see
that that acceptance of astrology
reflected um Jean Dixon American Psy
said as a child I was taught caldan
astrology by a wise and wonderful man a
Jesuit priest father Henry I don't see
how anyone can say that astrology was
wrong after all he was a man of
God of course these were her predictions
in 1985 she was well known as a psychic
and you know they promoted things like
murder for those who injured honor or
covered up infamy uh covered with infamy
before Persons Of Distinction not only
is it lawful to offer or accept duel but
you May secretly kill a calumniator so
there's that idea of secretly killing
somebody assassination M if you have no
other mode to avoid the danger because
it is not murder but
self-defense yeah so where's the um love
your enemies bless those who where's
that but also when they talk about
murder being um
premeditated like that is not
self-defense that is actually murder
yeah you know they said things like male
causes of lust male rapes are not
subject to ordinary law
punishment um or things like if a man
becomes a nuisance to society the son
may lawfully kill his
father very much uh shows how far they
went now this is a quiz right here see
if you guys can remember the scripture
text here Taberna says that the girl
does not sin if due to obvious danger of
death or great infamy she does not drive
away the rapist but merely tolerates
intercourse and this proposition is held
by more than 50 authors you guys
remember in uh what the Bible says about
that if you're under attack
what did you have to do you had to call
out mm yeah Deuteronomy
22:4 there was a a command that you know
the woman had to cry out for help and
and at least make that attempt so in
this case what they're saying is like
well if you're being a raped as a woman
you just go through with it and tolerate
it and just say nothing and pretend like
everything's fine yeah sounds very
normal to me not really yeah um this
particular Jesuit Clary bonarius said uh
this particular poem right here just
kind of to me it strikes me as a little
bit perverted where he's comparing the
breasts of Mary and the blending of milk
with Christ's blood as as this this
cordial that a sinful Soul can take uh
is Blasphemous why does this sound so
yeah I was about to say this sounds so
oul to me yeah uh this Jesuit right here
uh spoke about suicide and talked about
for the stoics have maintained that
self-destruction in our country's cause
is
Honorable they took a very very
different position on
suicide this one Antonio ketti said do
what your conscience tells you to be
good and commanded if through Invincible
error you believe lying or blasphemy to
be commanded by God blasphemy wow okay
so uh familiar spirits that seem
familiar to you but are telling you to
do certain things and get into your head
that's really Satan and his demons
you'll just do it we could shorten that
do what thou Wilt okay yeah do what thou
Wilt to be the whole of the law so
there's no moral standard there's no
moral standard true this one uh said
right here this was actually blae Pascal
who was a Catholic opposed to the
Jesuits he wrote up Leonard leius who
made this statement where lesus stated
in article four of his precepts on the
decalogue women do not sin mortally who
offer themselves to be viewed by the
young men by whom they believe to be
shamefully lusted after so it was okay
to Aiden a bet fornication to that
degree very much a concern in more
evidence of the man of sin now um this
book for anybody who's interested back
in the 19th century it was written by a
32nd degree Freemason uh called the
engineer core of Hell or Rome sappers
and Miners and it has all kinds of
additional quotes in English from the
Jesuit casuists for example this one
down here can a woman occasioned an
abortion and he gives some examples
right up here here where if a young
woman has been seduced and she repents
of her young adultery she can before the
fetus is animated for fear of losing her
honor which is more precious than her
own life commit abortion so yeah that's
going to get a lot of Christians angry
and I hope it does I hope that people if
you're looking at this at home I hope
you're seeing there's something really
scary going on and this is just fact
upon fact upon fact so this is an entire
book of situations where you can
actually
go against the word of God for any
reason yeah this this particular book
was written by a 32nd degree Freemason
he was protesting some of the Jesuits uh
what what a lot of people don't know
though is at the very top the it was
said that back in the 19th century that
the leader of the Freemasons was
ultimately the pope they were connected
at the very top but I could see that you
know work together as sort of a hegelian
dialectic uh as you said you know two
secret societies kind of Waring against
each other for the same end right it's
like they're writing the manual in
situational ethics yeah yeah yeah that's
what casu actually was was referring to
as cases what you can do in a specific
case and twist the law of God y now you
know one of the one of the examples that
we find of the sort of assassination
they did an interesting story back in
the 19th century this is Charles chinay
he was a convert a priest who converted
to protestantism wrote a book called 50
years in the Church of Rome incredible
book I recommend it it's awesome um but
you know he wrote about uh one of the
things was his lawyer who defended him
was a young Abraham Lincoln and he
warned Lincoln that later on you know he
had not made friends with the Jesuits in
defending this priest and uh that they
were going to seek his life and you know
later on we find that all of the
Catholics involved in the conspiracy to
to kill Abraham Lincoln um they they
were all Catholic and one of them the
leader John H Sarat was trapped
to Rome in the Pope's private Army in
the zaves and that was his papal uniform
right there you can see so there was
some question about some involvement and
in 1922 the suppressed truth about the
assassination of Abraham Lincoln by
Burke mccardy you can read about all the
details of that now mind you this is
1922 she says in that book that the next
step in the vatican's great scheme is to
make war between this country and Japan
after the latter country has been placed
under full Dominion of the Jesuits so
they wanted to get back into
Japan and what do we find a few years
after
1922 Pearl
Harbor yeah so there's a quote by
Abraham Lincoln where he says the war
referring to the Civil War would never
have been possible without the Sinister
influence of the Jesuits H and then also
Samuel Morse the one who invented Morse
code he also said that Jesuits our
secret soci society a sort of masonic
order with super added features of
revolting odiousness and a thousand
times more
dangerous there was a there was another
priest in 1913 Jeremiah Crowley who
wrote about the pope chief of white
slavers and high priest of intrigue who
said that Rome is now egging on Japan to
Annex Mexico's Seas on the Philippines
on Hawaii and Alaska and wipe out the
United States now this is 1913
and again long time before Pearl Harbor
took place but you know it looks Eerie
when you look back through the lens of
History you know World War II there's a
lot of concerning things about World War
II one of the things that we read from
rashing head of the Danzig government
1939 was that Hitler stated I learned
much from the order of the Jesuits until
now there has never been anything more
grandiose on the earth than the
hierarchical organization of the
Catholic church I transferred much of
this organization into my own party
interesting
MH you know Walter Schilling former
Chief of Nazi counter Espionage
indicated that the SS organization
constituted by himler according to the
principles of the Jesuit order their
regulations and spiritual exercises
prescribed by Ignatius Vala were the
model himler tried to copy exactly
exactly wow yeah and France Von Poppin
himself said that the Third Reich is is
the first Power which not only
recognizes but puts into practice the
high principles of the papacy in
De January 14th 1934 I find that very
interesting because at on the outside
you would never think that uh Hitler and
his organization had anything to do with
Catholicism right right they did not
come across as Christian if we could
call Catholicism Christian but they did
share a mutual disgust for Israel yeah
interesting okay you know the
Inquisition think about the Inquisition
there were a lot of Jews that got
persecuted in the Inquisition and Rome
just continued that in fact the idea of
gold stars that were in Germany that
comes that goes back to to uh councils
in Rome long before that that prescribed
that the Jews had to wear an identifying
feature and they also had to live in
cities in specific like ghettos so yeah
and they did that for other other people
groups too I mean the Jews they got the
the gold stars the two triangles opposed
to each other but there were other
groups that had other types of badges M
some triangles and squares and things
like that what what I find interesting
is that um if they were saying that we
they're very much inspired by the
Catholic church and putting those
practices into their system but on the
outside they didn't look Christian by
any means nothing about Jesus or God or
anything then what were they inspired by
clearly the only parallel you see is is
of the Jesuit order right and the
violence and occultism and the schwas
was also a part of Hinduism yeah so you
know what's their ultimate aims um I
think one of the things that that I've
been uh seeing here recently is you know
the encyclical fratti that Pope Francis
just recently introduced this is
actually right here a model in the chesa
Del jzu in Rome by venzo pandoli and
it's a model of this mother church and
we've got
uh all of these churches surrounding it
here and I got to ask how many doors
were there in the Old Testament
Sanctuary that was one entrance
representing that Jesus is the only way
exactly you know Revelation you you see
this story about a woman uh a harlot and
many daughters and here we have this
model of this church with all of these
churches around it and it's very much an
ecumenical movement that is uniting with
all of these different world religions
and one of the things that I see right
here is um there's there's anger over
converting Souls there's this anger over
there being an idea of absolute truth of
one true path but really establishing
many roads
instead yep and that's what you see too
um with many of the uh Protestant mostly
Evangelical actually leaders that will
come come to the pope have discussions
with the Pope and uh I think it was
actually the Lutheran Church that said
uh we the protest is over we're coming
back to the mother church we know that
the first thousand years there was one
church it was called the Catholic church
and the word Catholic means Universal it
doesn't mean Roman Catholic means if
you're born again raise your hand if
you're born again you're a
Catholic I've come to understand that
divers is divine it's division that's
diabolic the Roman Catholic church and
the Protestant Lutheran Church signed an
agreement that brought an end to the
protest this brought an end to the
protest of
Luther brothers and sisters Luther's
protest is
over is
yours
[Music]
fore
for the
beginning of the protesting
church now now you really stop think
about it among among the people of love
we're called
protesters we've been protesting for 500
years
baby when that church split took
place and that Spirit of
division sat down on his
throne we've been dividing ever since
you recognize James and Betty Robinson
they next to
Tony and then Jeff tunic Cliffe now Jeff
is Secretary General CEO of world
Evangelical
Alliance that
is uh one of the largest Evangelical
Association if not the largest in the
world and then uh down on this other end
is John and Carol arnet uh Partners in
Harvest in Toronto Canada you remember
the Toronto blessing
it broke up those are the pastors it
broke out in their
church and so they were there and then
Brian Stiller Global Ambassador World
Evangelical Alliance is the man right
right next to me there uh on the left
and then the tall guy in the back is Dr
Thomas Schumacher Martin buer
Theological Seminary and bond
Germany
now take a good look at that
picture the night before we had a dinner
together before we met with with Pope
Francis the next
day that many evangelicals in one
room uh folks you don't get it we ask
that you give him eyes to see with
hopeful longing the Fulfillment of
bringing together your brother Bride of
the church Lord God may it may it Pierce
all of our hearts that there is any
division in your bride the
church and Lord we just ask you to
inspire our hearts in every way to
overcome every obstacle every Prejudice
every
misunderstanding every
shortcoming and that we would see in
each other brothers and sisters longing
to be faithful to your son the glory
that the father had he gave to Jesus the
glory was the presence of God what is
the charismatic renewal is when we
experience the presence of God and he
said and I give them the glory pragmatic
reason so that they may be one it's the
glory that glues us together not the
doctrines it's the glory if you accept
that Christ is living in me and the
presence of God is in me and the
presence of God is in you that's all we
need because God will sort out all our
doctrines when we get
upstairs therefore Christian Unity is
the basis of our credibility because
Jesus said until they won they will not
believe the world will not believe as
they should Until We Are One Division
destroys our
credibility it is fear that keeps us
separated because fear is false evidence
appearing real it's an acronym f e a r
false evidence appearing real because
most of your fear is based on propaganda
yeah their goal of of destroying the
Reformation has almost been completed in
in the majority of the Protestant world
the question is is where are those real
Protestants today who still oppose this
system who still haven't swerved from
the position of the reformers you know
hundreds of years ago and still uphold
truth wow I I'm really glad you came
James because I knew a little bit about
the Jesuits from maybe we can hold up
the book uh the great
controversy um again historical facts
what James presented a lot of that is
also in the great controversy which you
can get in many places and even online
for free and and I would highly
recommend you read this because many
lives have been changed by but people
reading the book and realizing whoa
there is something more happening behind
the scenes and I'll add just right there
please go read the 50 years in the
Church of Rome by chiniki it is amazing
it changed my whole perspective yeah
yeah definitely James thank you so much
for coming today uh James has his
YouTube channel biblical hope please go
and support him and subscribe I'm
subscribed and he has awesome uh content
out there again historical Christian
history and just showing you as he did
here today fact fact fact fact and he
does not play around with it he just
tells you the straight up truth and I
want the straight truth I want to know
what what's going on because as the
Bible says the truth shall make you free
so thank you so much for watching if you
like this video please hit like And
subscribe and comment it helps get this
video out in the algorithm so more
people can see it share it with your
friends your family share with people
who need to know also if you want to
support us financially we really
appreciate that you can do so at
website we get the full amount patreon
does take a cut and also we've got
t-shirts Keith wearing one right now
we've got t-shirts on our website light
wear. shop and you can wear your Witness
by wearing Christian merchandise thank
you so much and we'll see you next week
bye
[Music]
if you're looking for good wholesome
educational content for your children
subscribe to our new channel little
light kids it's proven that people
remember things that they see more than
what they hear lightwear believes the
best way to share your witness is to
wear your witness lightwear has all
kinds of graphic te's that are a great
attention grabbing way to share the
gospel so head on over to lightwear do
shop and check out all the cool graphic
te's what do you want people to remember
when they see you do you have questions
about the Bible that you've been
struggling to find the answers for video
Bible study or VBS for short is a
YouTube channel that answers your Bible
questions in 5 minutes or less check out
these easy to understand comprehensive
videos talking about everything from
what happens when you die to why does
God allow suffering make it your goal to
deepen your relationship with Christ
this year and subscribe to video bible
study on YouTube to help you along your
journey
[Music]
oh